merci à tous d'être là sauf entendez
républicain qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
week-end donc les il faut qu'on aille à
la rencontre de tout le monde où il faut
qu'on soit présent sur le terrain oui il
faut qu'on marque ce qui est notre adn
et notre identité nous les républicains
s'emparent du terrain
c'est un moment aussi où je vous demande
pendant le week-end de bien écouter tout
ce que les gens nous disent parce que ma
conviction c'est que en ce moment nous
raconte une belle histoire mais que la
réalité qui est la réalité profonde du
pays
c'est tout autre chose reconnaissons
bien laurent wauquiez on est très
heureux qu'il ait voulu mettre en oeuvre
ce printemps des républicains pour
montrer tout simplement quoique les
républicains sont actifs que les
républicains ne sont plus que jamais
opposé à la politique d' emmanuel macron
ce matin on a tracté on a eu un apéritif
convivial avec laurent wauquiez le
printemps de la pub lique 1 dans notre
eau notre fédération c'était l'occasion
d'échanger avec beaucoup de gens d'ici
qu'ils nous ont confié un petit peu
justement leurs difficultés et il était
content de voir qu'ils avaient des élus
et des gens qui se battaient vraiment
pour faire passer les idées du
territoire en un mot on est mobilisé
pour que la france reste la france
mon engagement c'est que la vocation de
la famille et républicain c'est de
redonner ses valeurs et ses fondations à
la république française vive les
républicains vive la république et que
met de l'avant
[Applaudissements]